das hier ist das fünfte der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs wild Staffel 2
viel Spaß mit dem Interview von Otto
wie hast du dich auf deine Teilnahme von
Seven vs white Staffel 2 vorbereitet ihr
vorbereitet ja eingelesen natürlich ein
paar so Dinge das ich war selber schon
mal Benutzer Ela in Brasilien habe da
schon Dschungel survival gemacht aber
durchschlagen im Inland nicht auf eine
Insel muss man sagen dazu und schon
vorbereitet ne ich habe mich mit
Kameraden vom Bundeswehr getroffen die
dschungelkampfausbilder sind das ist
natürlich auch taktisches dabei was
jetzt hier
völlig interessant ist aber natürlich
auch das ganze mal Leben im Feld ist
oder nächstes mal was wir da draußen
gemacht haben
ja ob wir schon länger reingezogen
gerade am Büchern und Austausch mit
Kumpels und Kameraden und Sachen
getestet selber
fand ich gut weil ich war doch Spaß
gemacht muss ich sagen richtig Spaß
kannst du uns ein wenig erzählen wie du
dich Equipment technisch vorbereitet
hast auch wenn es bei dir scheinbar
wenig auszuwählen gab sind ja eine Menge
Gedanken und Planung in dein Gegenstand
geflossen ja du meinst in einen
Gegenstand ne also es war ja alles klar
ich nur ein Gegenstand Fritz genauso im
Gegenstand der Türkei der muss schon
ganz ganz besonders werden und da ist
natürlich die Entscheidung entweder wird
zum Machete oder das wird ein Feuerstahl
ne oder man hat auch Wasserfilter nehmen
können aber ich weiß ja guten Morgen
brauche ich kein Wasserfilter Feuer ich
denke so jetzt kommt so eine Essen klar
aber ich muss mir auf jeden Fall
irgendwas bauen oder irgendwo
durchkommen also kannst du die Machete
sein und ähm Kumpel von mir haben halt
ein kleines Unternehmen wirklich
ministart ab aus dem Sauerland aber
hochtechnisiert mit wo die Messer mit
Titan angegriffen machen dann habe ich
gesagt was auf können wir nicht
irgendwie man eigentlich gar keine
Macheten
ja klar machen und dann hat sie
Entstehungsprozess in Gang gesetzt
worden mit Zeichnung was ist schön oder
was gefällt mir was Funktion habe wie
können die Schleifen mit verschiedenen
Stärken was kann man noch mit einbauen
also diese kleine Ecke oben zum
Kokosnüsse knacken
Schalen Knacken von Krebstieren zum
Beispiel und so ist halt wirklich da
haben wir eine
Prototypen da gehabt den ich erstmal
richtig auf Herz und Nieren getestet
habe noch ein bisschen was verändert und
der Gegenstand ist mir halt mega ans
Herz gewachsen was ist meine Machete
selber entworfen was ich anderthalb
Monate Arbeit reingesteckt also wirklich
Liebe Wissen kleinste Detail und ich ich
liebe meinen Gegenstand einfach also und
bin mega happy mit dem da reingegangen
zu sein nicht nur das unterschiedlich
viele Gegenstände für die verschiedenen
Teilnehmer gab auch der drop of wurde
weiter auf die Spitze getrieben wie war
der Tag für dich wach werden ich weiß ja
im letzten Jahr hat das Orga-Team die
Leute wach geklingelt um 5 Uhr
ja ich war um 2 Uhr wach bin dann
erstmals Stimme reingegangen bisschen
Runde trainiert und ich bin Uniform
angelegt habe ich tanzschminke aufgelegt
habe ich alles klar dann wechsel jetzt
mal das orgativ wenn die mich nicht
wecken mach ich das heißt habe dann den
Max erwischt der dich völlig verschlafen
dann mir die Tür aufgemacht hat mir was
los ich sag wann hey wann geht's los
Freunde ich bin ready ja hat man noch
ein bisschen Zeit morgen früh quasi noch
mal zu quatschen bevor es dann wirklich
losgehen auch zu frühstücken ähm dann
konnte sich so ein bisschen erahnen eine
Insel okay wir waren Panama City also
irgendwie müssen wir diese Insel
hinkommen
man konnte die auch so ein bisschen
okay vielleicht mit Helis vielleicht mit
Booten also im letzten Jahr ja dann sind
wir zum Flughafen gefahren und sind aber
nicht in Heli eingestiegen sondern ein
Flugzeug haben gemacht
mega schön kleine Maschine konnte mal
echt sehen von oben sieht das aus wie
grün ist das eigentlich weil wir Panama
nicht wirklich kennengelernt bis jetzt
oder Panama City und es war wirklich
wirklich schön das sind oben manchmal so
ein Feeling gegeben alles klar jetzt
kannst du dich losgehen ich war heiß auf
jeden Fall ich weiß die anderen auch
oder zum großteils aber jetzt lass uns
endlich loslegen dann sind wir hier auf
dieser Insel gelandet auf dieser kleinen
Landebahn mit einem grünen die Aras
flogen schon da lang und das war so
richtig alles klar die Luft hat
irgendwie schon ein bisschen vibriert
jetzt kann es echt losgehen ja dann
schon die Heli ist natürlich da ist dann
wie super ist das denn ich liebe aus dem
Heli Fallschirmspringen oder fast zu
sein und so und dann noch eine Belle
also paprikant was der halt oder Modell
was richtig vom Sound hinter dieser
Teppich Klopfer ich liebe es halt
einfach eingestiegen ja und dann erstmal
losgeschraubt und die Flüge dann da
gemacht der offenen Tür also es war
einfach schon
ja mich versetzt das immer so ein
bisschen in der dienstlei zurück wo wir
genau das gemacht haben mit Türen auf
raus Nachtsichtgerät und du hast die
tollsten Flüge und hier natürlich an der
tropischen Insel bitte wie geil ist das
also
BAM da kann man eigentlich nur
explodieren der Kopf von von den ganzen
Informationen und Eindrücken und erstmal
diese dieser Geschichte mit mit diesen
drei Helis geflogen und bist du erst
dann ausgesetzt worden ist also wir
konnten Flug genießen das war sie nicht
Pop und raus sondern wirklich diese
Insel mal einen saugen die Eindrücke von
außen dann Hauptsätzen knossi niemals
Glück gewünscht und äh dann Nova raus ja
da war ich dran und ich habe mir einfach
nur gefreut alles klar dann noch ein
bisschen spürt es in der Luft gemacht
jetzt nicht ganz normal darunter raus
ja runter zack an Land äh in den
Wellengang bei mir war natürlich kein
Sandstrand sondern wirklich grobe Steine
das heißt ich bin so ein bisschen anhand
gestolpert aber dann irgendwie auf Puls
alles klar vorwärts Sie zu dass du water
Schuhe Shelter food also die drei Sachen
abgepackt bekommst abgebacken Wasser
halt ganz ganz wichtig sofort Pflanzen
alles klar
einer schon vom Baum geholt
aufgeschlagen die man nicht passend eine
andere dann nach vorne alles klar die
war passend da ich gesehen
Süßwasserquelle ist okay Check an Wasser
ganzen Haken machen ich habe immer
Wasser jetzt bekommt man nach Shelter
habe dann eine tolle Ecke gefunden und
war ein geiler Start also scheinbar viel
Spaß beim drop of card wie war es dann
aber als am Tag drei die Tropenstürme
losgehen ist völlig anfängt zu regnen
und es richtig gescheppert hat ich liebe
extremes Wetter ich liebe Wirklich
donnerblätter das war ein so ein
episches Gefühl du bist dann da und
hörst dieses ganz intensive Donnern und
Blitzen also wirklich
[ __ ] Gewalt das dann in seiner Natur zu
erleben was anderes im Auto aus dem Haus
raus sei einfach so so klar das ganze
Gefühl davon ich fand's mega ich fand es
richtig cool dass dann einfach richtig
das losgelegt hat auch mal so die taffe
Seite
der Natur
hat schon Bock gemacht ich fand's mega
also kein Problem mit dem Unwetter
gehabt was nimmst du Positives für dich
aus der Zeit mit ich denke immer recht
viel nach bevor ich die Natur also ich
bin kein Mensch der irgendwie also ich
kann sehr sehr spontan sein wenn es
heißt alles klar jetzt Heli
Fallschirmspringen mache ich das aber
ansonsten so um Entscheidung was das
Leben angeht wo möchte ich hingehen das
habe ich mir auch vorgenommen
tatsächlich hier auf der Insel länger
drüber nachzudenken oder was soll das
von mir passieren weil ich auch so ein
bisschen am Scheideweg stehe ich habe
eine Firma aufgebaut die super läuft und
noch ein paar Beteiligungen und sowas
aber ist das das was mein Herz erfreut
will ich den Weg weiter einschlagen oder
mache ich den irgendwie automatisierbar
und lass ihn durch jemanden führen und
machen mehr weil YouTube ist ja für mich
noch recht neu ist etwas mehr als ein
Jahr erst ähm einfach mehr da rein weil
es einfach super Spaß macht und man
ehrlich wenn man mit dem wo man was Herz
dran hängt auch noch alles sich leisten
kann was man sich muss und wir jetzt
nicht von irgendeine
ja dann ist das so eine Entscheidung die
ich hier auf der Insel auch mitgenommen
habe und zwar in die Richtung
Outdoor und Youtube da muss ich
vielleicht mal zu fragen um paar Tipps
weil ich null Ahnung davon hab was ich
habe erst in 7 Stream hinter mir bei
Twitch sind zwar schon echt viele Leute
mit drin keine Ahnung was man
unterschrieben wird die Leute amüsieren
sich natürlich Otto gegen den Rechner
oder gegen die IT äh beim Bund hatte ich
meine funknamen Magneto du kriegst immer
so Funken haben zugeteilt eigentlich
Wolverine weil viele Unfälle einfach
über einfach nichts hatte und überlebt
habe aber dann Magneto war weil ich auf
einem Einsatz alles ist kaputt gegangen
hätte ich das Mikro ist in die Hand
genommen danach Nico geht nicht mehr
keine Ahnung warum Mikro kaputt
Spaß besonders du hast die Zeit für dich
alleine genossen was lief aber
vielleicht nicht so gut was hätte besser
laufen können oder was war dein größtes
Problem also Problem gar nicht ehrlich
gesagt weil so Situationen schon viele
hatte wo es jetzt alleine sein in
Situationen schon auf noch Wilderer
Witterungsbedingungen ganz viele Regen
Essen schlaf mal egal was wo ich ganz
ganz ganz oft schon gehabt Thema hat mir
eigentlich nur echt gemacht dadurch dass
ich schon Hinflug oder zwei Tage vorher
bevor es angefangen hat hier sollt mich
hat irgendwo einen Rücken Wirbel eine
falsche Bewegung gemacht und seitdem ist
ganz tief im Gesäßmuskel irgendeiner der
einfach nur gespannt gezerrt irgendwas
ist und das komplett und das hat mir
einfach ein bisschen Behinderten das war
echt nervig von der von den Schmerzen
Alter weil ich mich nicht so frei
bewegen konnte und Liegen wetert Sitzen
erst recht gehen gehen geht und stehen
geht und ja muss was das einzige
eigentlich ja also sonst alles tutti
sehr cool dass du trotzdem durchgezogen
hast mit einem Gegenstand sind die
Möglichkeiten ja ziemlich limitiert
welchen Gegenstand hättest Du zusätzlich
gerne dabei gehabt oder die in der Woche
herbei gewünscht nee ich hätte sogar
eher noch meinen abgegeben und gesagt
alles klar noch ein bisschen soll ich
euch die Entscheidung gefällt am Tag
zwei schon morgens früh ich lass Essen
weg nächsten Samstag eine Kokosnuss mehr
vom Baum geholt nach ich weiß was kommt
eine Schippe drauf wir lassen Nahrung
komplett weg ja ich hätte den Gegenstand
abgegeben dazu würdest Du Deinem besten
Freunden so eine Erfahrung auch mal
wünschen oder sogar ans Herz legen das
tue ich tatsächlich ist auch von mir so
ein kleines Herzensprojekt denn ich habe
vor ein paar Wochen so ein
eltern-kind-wochenende gemacht vor free
für allem sonst wo halt auf dem Hof
meines Vaters der hat so ein hobbyhof er
ist genannt wird
25 Kinder da und irgendwie 15 18
Elternteile und mit denen wirklich
Wasserfiltern Feuer machen Shelter bauen
einfach als Gemeinschaftsgefühl
zusammenwachsen wieder die Natur zu
gehen ich kann das jedem nur empfehlen
horizonter weiter Komfortzone vor allem
für viele viele überfordert jetzt
rauszuschlafen sehen wir mal einen
knossi wo hat er angefangen und wo ist
der jetzt beendet die Tage durch von ich
weiß gar nicht wie ein Feuerstarter
funktioniert ich weiß in einem
Feuerstahl ich weiß gar nichts zu da ist
jetzt draußen das wird ihnen deswegen
habe ich noch immer gut gerettet gesagt
pass auf in dem schlummert was er muss
nur gucken dass er den Schalter umgelegt
bekommt
kann ich jedem raten nur um das
Abschließen ja gab es in den sieben
Tagen für dich mal einen Moment an dem
du wirklich überlegt hast abzubrechen
bzw was wäre ein Moment gewesen in dem
du den Knopf gedrückt hättest also
Moment gab es gar nicht mich raus und zu
lassen also der Kopf spielt weder
verrückt und ich habe da nichts was
irgendwie wo ich denke jetzt muss ich
mich herausholen lassen also gar nichts
was hätte dazu führen können eine
schwere Verletzung also wirklich eine
schwer ich bin auch selber
gucken können ist das jetzt schwer komme
ich damit weil der Ehrgeiz packt dann ja
schon damit noch diese zwei drei vier
Tage oder nicht aber eine schwere
Verletzung wo ich weiß okay mit offener
Bruch wäre schwer Verletzung weil es
einfach dumm wenn das nicht infiziert
muss man abgenommen bekommen da hätte
ich auch gedrückt ja
dann herzlichen Glückwunsch vielen Dank
fürs Interview und in den nächsten
Wochen Monaten und Jahren viel Spaß auf
Youtube danke euch
[Musik]